es ist von beschuss von explosionen von
raketenbeschuss zu hören mein gott
buchstein ukraine das schlägt bei uns
allen bei uns und auch hier auf einem
flugplatz in der west ukraine
er hat es getan wladimir putin greift
die ukraine an hey ich bin aminata
valley und in dieser kontext folge soll
es um das gehen was uns von alle seit
wochen beschäftigt wie konnte es zum
angriffskrieg russlands gegen die
ukraine kommen am 24 februar bin ich
aufgewacht und habe in meinem news mit
gesehen dass russland die ukraine
angegriffen hat ich war erschüttert und
betroffen ehrlich gesagt habe ich nicht
damit gerechnet wie war es bei euch
[Musik]
ob das so genannte slawische dreieck
russland die ukraine und weißrussland
nur einen riss bekommen hat oder ob es
zerbrochen ist bleibt abzuwarten
heute befindet sich russland im krieg
mit der ukraine und nutzt belarus früher
auch als weißrussland bezeichnet als
aufmarschgebiet
mit dem zerfall der sowjetunion vor etwa
30 jahren ende zwei der kalte krieg doch
das ende des staatenbundes bringt neue
spannung mit sich der aufruf sowohl geld
ziehen sie gorbatschows an die ukraine
die katastrophe der abspaltung des 50
millionen volkes zu vermeiden stieß auf
taube ohren nur ein paar monate vor
diesem ausschnitt am 24 august 1991
folgte der ukraine dem beispiel anderer
sowjetrepubliken und erklärt ihre
unabhängigkeit in einem referendum
bestätigten die ukraine in dieses
schritt eindeutig mehr als 90 prozent
stimmten für die unabhängigkeit selbst
auf der halbinsel krim mit überwiegend
russischer bevölkerung waren es etwa 54
prozent mit dem ende der sowjetunion
endete auch die russische imperiale
herrschaft über andere voelker putin
bezeichnete den zusammenbruch der
sowjetunion 2005 als größte
geopolitische katastrophe des 20
jahrhunderts diese position betonte auch
2011 noch mal man hätte in der
sowjetunion rechtzeitig mit
wirtschaftlichen veränderungen beginnen
und sie mit demokratischen reformen
untermauern sollen
man hätte dafür kämpfen müssen dass
unser staatsterritorium unversehrt
bleibt
und zwar hätte man das konsequent
beharrlich furchtlos tun müssen
und dabei den kopf nicht in den sand
stecken
russland zusammen und wir möchten jetzt
machten
frei und unabhängig sein und jetzt
darum öffnen wäre das risiko und sehr
präsident der typ sein
2004 protestieren viele ukraine ein weil
es bei der präsidentschaftswahl zu
wahlbetrug zugunsten des pro-russischen
präsidentschaftskandidaten janukowitsch
gekommen waren bei der wiederholung der
wahl setzte sich der pro westliche
kandidat luzenko durch die sogenannte
orangene revolution ist der erste
offizielle riss in der beziehung der
beiden ehemaligen sowjetrepubliken
ukraine und russland neun jahre später
weigert sich janukowitsch mittlerweile
tatsächlich zum präsidenten gewählt ein
assoziierungsabkommen mit der eu zu
unterzeichnen welches vor allem die
wirtschafts und handelsbeziehungen
zwischen der ukraine und der eu stärken
sollen stattdessen liebäugelt er mit
einer zollunion mit russland
erneut gehen die menschen auf die straße
dieses zurück zu russland nutzt ja wohl
nur den oligarchen und ist überhaupt
nicht im sinne des volkes deswegen
demonstrieren
sondereinheiten des innenministeriums
versuchen die proteste gewaltsam
aufzulösen es kommt zu blutigen
auseinandersetzungen janukowitsch
verlässt das land zum zweiten mal
erfährt russland dass es keinen
hundertprozentigen einfluss auf die
entwicklung in der ukraine hat um zu
verstehen wie es zum krieg russlands
gegen die ukraine kommen konnte hilft es
auch sich anzuschauen wie russland unter
putin mit anderen konflikten umgegangen
ist denn der krieg gegen die ukraine ist
nicht der erste den putin beginnt wir
würden die terroristen überall hin
verfolgen notfalls machen wir sie auch
auf dem scheiß haushalt 1999 befehligt
putin damals noch als ministerpräsident
den zweiten tschetschenienkrieg
offizieller auslöser war eine bis heute
nicht aufgeklärte anschlagsserie in
russland für die tschetschenische
rebellen verantwortlich
2008 unterstützt russland die nach
unabhängigkeit strebenden regionen
südossetien und abchasien in georgien
krieg ohne weitreichende folgen oder
sanktionen aus dem westen im februar
2014 besetzt russland an die ukrainische
halbinsel krim angeblich um russische
landsleute zu schützen eine
argumentation die putin auch im
aktuellen krieg verwendet vor allem
erging es dem kreml herrscher aber um
die schwarzmeer häfen auf der halbinsel
dort liegt ein wichtiger teil der
russischen flotte von hier aus hat
putins armee zugang zum mittelmeer also
aus russland sicht zur nato gebiet
entschlossen baut russland die übernahme
der krim aus und die ukraine ist hilflos
sie zieht ihr militär nun ganz ab aufs
festland vorübergehend im osten der
ukraine rufen im gleichen jahr pro
russische separatist in unabhängige
volksgruppe bieten aus es kommt zu
kriegerischen auseinandersetzungen laut
un sind dabei von 2014 bis 2021 zwischen
14214 1400 menschen ums leben gekommen
seit 2005 10 mischt sich russland auf
der seite des assad-regimes militärisch
in syrien krieg ein experten sprechen
davon dass der einsatz in syrien so
etwas wie ein versuchslabor für uster
gewesen sei um waffen und militärische
strategien zu testen im april 2021
begann russland an der grenze zur
ukraine truppen zu versammeln dass putin
den einsatz von militär für legitim hält
hat er bis dahin mehrfach bewiesen viele
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer haben in den
letzten wochen erzählt dass sie auch
trotz alldem nicht mit einem angriff
gerechnet haben am 24 februar passierte
dann was viele von uns sich nicht hätte
vorstellen können wir haben gehofft dass
es nicht passiert es ist unbegreiflich
dass ein verrückter mann so einen befehl
heute müssen doch fest und endgültig
erklären der kalte krieg ist vorbei
wie auch immer versucht uns zu stoppen
oder unser land bedroht der sollte
wissen dass russlands antwort schnell
sein wird und konsequenzen hat solche
die es in der geschichte so noch nicht
gab wenn ich mir diese beiden reden
anschaue und die kurz nach beginn seiner
präsidentschaft und putin heute frage
ich mich was es passiert dass sich der
ton so geändert hat auf der suche nach
erklärungen für die aktuelle eskalation
muss man immer wieder auf ein thema die
nato osterweiterung in seiner
kriegserklärung bezeichnet putin die
ausdehnung des nato blogs osten als
bedrohung für russland und er sieht in
ihr einen historischen wortbruch da
stellt sich die frage welche rolle
spielte der westen bei dieser eskalation
nicht dass nicht die absicht besteht das
radio verteidigungs gebiet auszudehnen
nach osten das sagte bundesaußenminister
genscher nach einem treffen mit dem
amerikanischen außenminister james baker
1990 hat putin also recht so erinnert
sich ein anderer wichtiger akteur der
damals an den verhandlungen zur
wiedervereinigung deutschlands beteiligt
heute fragt man mich warum es nicht
vertraglich fixiert wurde dass die nato
sich nicht nach müssen ausziehen darf
dazu sollte man folgendes
berücksichtigen
damals existierte die nato und der
warschauer pakt bis heute man da
vertraglich fixieren die frage stellte
sich damals gar nicht
wenn putin also heute vom wortbruch der
nato spricht ist es nicht besonders
glaubwürdig in der ukraine befürchten
schon 97 manche dass es zum schutz der
unabhängigkeit die nato braucht wenn sie
unabhängig bleiben wollen wenn russland
uns nicht erdrücken soll haben wir nur
eine wahl das zusammengehen mit der nato
obwohl der wunsch in der ukraine da ist
gibt es bis heute keine konkrete
perspektive auf einen nato beitritt
es gibt nur eine diskussion über
georgien und die ukraine
hier ist es so dass es unstrittig ist
dass beide länder eine perspektive für
die nato haben sollen das auch
vollkommen klar ist dass die
nato-mitgliedstaaten darüber entscheiden
wer zukünftiges mitglied ist das heißt
nicht andere zum beispiel russland wir
sind zu der überzeugung gelangt dass ist
allerdings noch zu früh ist das ist kein
thema das uns wahrscheinlich in unseren
ämtern begegnen wird wieder so lange wir
sie ausüben ich weiß jetzt nicht wie
lange der präsident vor hat dem amt zu
sein aber ich jedenfalls heftiges gefühl
das könnte länger dauern aber nicht ewig
ab und es kanzler scholz hatte kurz vor
beginn des russischen angriffs also noch
mal betont dass ein nato-beitritt der
ukraine nicht in absehbarer zeit
bevorstehe als russland 2014 die ukraine
schon mal überfallen hat die krim
annektiert hat und die region dann jetzt
und lohans in dornbach setzt hat
völkerrechtswidrig war das nicht die
reaktion auf die nato ideen der ukraine
sondern das war die reaktion darauf dass
sich die ukraine gen europa gewandt hat
und ein freier liberaler westlicher
staat werden wollte das heißt das
problem nato ist ein problem dass
russland uns versucht in den diskurs vor
zu schmeißen worum es überhaupt nicht
ging worum es putin tatsächlich geht
russlands einflussgebiet geografisch
liegt die ukraine zwischen der eu
ostgrenze und russland die frage in
welche richtung sie sich politisch und
wirtschaftlich orientiert hat in der
vergangenheit immer wieder zu konflikten
geführt wurden will diese frage nun
gewaltsam entscheiden es war ein sehr
pulsierende neues land so gesehen ein
offenes freies land und natürlich ist
das an der grenze russland hat eine
wahnsinnig große grenze mehr kleine und
das ist über geschraubt diese
informationsquelle und diese lust am
leben ist immer über gestoppt und es war
immer eine bedrohung für putins regime
ein regime das sich im inneren auf
repression und propaganda stützt und im
außen auf militärische mittel setzt wie
konnte es also soweit kommen nach dem
was wir uns angeschaut haben liegen die
hauptursachen mit putins verständnis von
herrschaft und geopolitik und seiner
über jahre aufgebauten macht als
staatschef gleichzeitig ging es dem
westen zu lange um wirtschaftliche
vorteile
dabei wurde über die demokratischen
defizite hinweggesehen darunter leiden
die menschen in der ukraine und ihre
familien und freundinnen und freunde
es ist so schwer gestern haben wir ein
feuer gelöscht heute wieder 1 die leute
sterben am schlimmsten ist es wenn
kinder sterben sie haben ihr leben noch
nicht gelebt und sehen jetzt dass das
ist das schlimmste
eine aktuelle entwicklung verfolgen und
weitere analysen zum russland ukraine
krieg sehen wollt abonniert am besten
direkt unseren kanal und hier gibt es
eine playlist mit allen videos zum thema
mehr videos von context findet ihr dann